une solidarité à toute épreuve dans ce
petit village espagnol situé au
nord-ouest dans la province de la
corogne plusieurs motards se sont portés
volontaires pour fournir des devoirs à
des centaines d'enfants privés de moyens
modernes pour pouvoir imprimer leurs
cours
il y avait beaucoup de garçons et de
filles qui en raison du conflit n'en
n'avaient pas accès aux tâches qui leur
étaient envoyées par voie électronique
depuis les écoles nous avons mis en
place un service pour les enfants de la
ville qui n'ont pas les moyens
techniques et économiques et qui ne sont
pas en mesure d'imprimer leurs devoirs
des bénévoles au style atypique qui
n'hésite pas à enfourcher leur engin et
braver le confinement pour pouvoir aider
un maximum les populations les plus
reculées
on estime que 200 familles ont déjà
adhéré au programme dans cette région
depuis sa mise en oeuvre la semaine
dernière le système fonctionne en
envoyant les devoirs des enfants au
conseil municipal où les copies sont
faites est ensuite distribuée par les
volontaires formés par la protection
civile et le club de moto coluna harley
davidson
il y avait une pénurie de bénévoles pour
fournir ses devoirs aux enfants de la
municipalité qui avait du mal à obtenir
leurs devoirs en raison d'un manque de
photocopies ou d'accès à internet à la
maison etc
nous avons donc pensé que pour atteindre
les ménages éloignés il est souvent plus
facile et plus rapide de le faire sur
une moto nous nous sommes donc porté
volontaire car nous pouvons atteindre
ces zones et apporter tous les documents
nécessaires
nous avons donc créé ce groupe de
volontaires pour apporter le matériel à
tous les garçons qui en ont besoin
[Musique]
un projet plus qu'apprécié dans la
région pour rappel le gouvernement
espagnol a annoncé l'état d'urgence
depuis le 14 mars dernier et a été
prolongée jusqu'au 26 avril au moins par
le premier ministre pedro sanchez amis